- So seriously, how fun was last night?
- I never thought I'd say these words,
but yes, that one woman
show, was fun last night.
(chuckles)
= It was.
- Good morning.
- Yay.
(clapping)
- Okay, okay, I'll give you that.
- Thank you.
Oh my God, your house is incredible.
This place is amazing.
Thank you for letting me stay here.
- You were so incredible last night.
- Shut up.
- So good, Mindy.
- Thank you.
I don't know, well I've
been working on it.
You know, but I was just thinking,
I was thinking, I wonder what Veronica
would say about this place, you know?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Who's Veronica?
- She's one of the main characters
in the one woman show.
- Remember?
I think she'd be like,
um, thanks for lettin' me
hang me hat in your flat, sir.
Bing!
(laughs)
- Oh my God, I love that.
I can't do it, this is
why you're on stage.
- Uh oh, look at this man,
this manly man,
what are those?
Those are muscles, those
are big, big muscles.
How'd you get those muscles, lad?
How'd you get those muscles?
I think he plays with his dick.
(laughs)
I think it's from playing
with his dick a lot.
I think he goes in the loo
and he goes, aw, aw, aw, aw, aw.
Aw, aw, aw.
Is that how you got those muscles?
- Uh, yeah.
- I think it's my favorite character
in the whole show.
I love it so much.
- [Mindy] She's my favorite character too,
she's just fun you know, she's just fun.
- That's what she'd say,
if she were a real person.
- Well, speaking of real people,
oh my God Jason, you look amazing.
Seriously though, how do you keep
your hands off this guy?
- Well, you know, he
doesn't make any money so
it's not hard.
- Oh, that is the only
thing that is not hard.
Hello, oh my God, you are amazing.
- What are you doin' there?
- What do you do?
- I mean, I work out a little bit.
- Obviously, well obviously, hello, yeah.
- I, you know, I take,
I take Treadmill Blast with Lars.
- I don't know what that is.
- It's a class at the gym.
- [Jason] Yeah, but you wouldn't know it,
you're in New York but yeah.
- Well you know, while I'm here,
maybe one night we'll, you know,
we'll have some chardonnay,
maybe all get in the Jacuzzi together
or something, while I'm here.
- Oh Mindy.
- [Mindy] What?
- I know where you are going with this.
- [Mindy] Well come with
me, uh, uh, come on.
Let's do this.
- You are so bad, stop it.
- [Mindy] Come on.
- No, Jason and I,
that's not, we don't ...
Mmm we're not going to
sleep together, Mindy.
- I'm not talking about sleeping.
Bam!
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
(laughs)
Come on, don't answer now.
- [Wife] You are..
- What, we're grown adults.
We can touch each other's naked parts.
- [Wife] What?
- What?
We can get in a Jacuzzi,
we can undress each other
and we can, you know, sort of tickle
and just see what happens.
We don't have to commit
to anything right now.
- Oh my God, you know.
- Come on.
- I don't think, I mean Jason and I,
it's not how we roll in our marriage.
Right, Jason?
Jason?
- What?
What'd you say?
(laughs)
- [Mindy] You don't have
to decide right now.
- No, no, that's, yeah.
- But I mean, just think about it.
- No, we're not into that.
We don't, we don't like
that, we don't like that.
- But you know, you don't
know who you are necessarily.
Oh my God, ahhh.
- You know, you guys, if you guys want to,
I mean, well I would
be interested in that.
(laughter)
- But we want to.
- Who would vote for okay?
- Yes, okay.
- Well I guess I'm out-voted.
So I guess we have to do it.
So when do you want to do this?
- Oh no, what are you doing up?
Oh my God.
- Oh, there's the guy
that we're looking for.
Let's get drunk tonight.
(laughter)
- Let's do, let's do it, let's get in.
- Really?
- Splish splash.
♫ I was takin a bath'
(laughter)
- I'm gonna go get my suit,
do you want to borrow one?
- Not really.
(screams and giggles)
I'll put one on.
(clapping)
- She's always had smooth skin.
- It's that dry brush I use,
you know, that dry brush.
Um, is this weird, I
feel like this is weird.
- No, this is not weird at all.
- I'm getting un-drunk and I
feel like maybe it's weird.
- This is the right thing to do,
this feels good, for everybody.
- You know what, I'm gonna
get us some more drinks.
- I will have a drink.
- Okay.
- More drinks.
- More drinks, more drinks.
- Awkward situation, I'll be right back.
- [Jason] There's nothing to
worry about, this is really...
- God, she's got a great ass.
- Yeah, she does, she really does.
Thank you for noticing that.
Cause she really, she works out.
- Well we all have to, you do.
- She tries, you know, she tries so hard.
I said, you don't even
have to work out that hard,
you look great, I don't care, you know.
- Come sit a little
closer, I can't hear you.
- Oh.
- Loud, you know.
That's better.
You do look great.
- You look really good too.
- You know what Veronica
would say if she was here?
- Who?
- Can I dip my toe in your bubbly?
(laughs)
- Oh yeah.
- Tip my toe in the
bubbly, that's the Jacuzzi.
- You're doing.
- You call it a Jacuzzi.
- You're doing Veronica
again, from the show.
- Hello gov'ner, hello gov'ner.
A knock, knock.
- Yeah.
- Who's there?
- Gov'ner.
- Gov'ner's there, all right.
- Gov'ner's there.
- Who's there.
- [Both] Gov'ner.
(laughs)
- You know what, Veronica is um,
Veronica's great.
- Thank ya, thank ya so much.
- You know who I like even better?
- Who?
- I like Mindy.
So maybe.
- Well Mindy's not here,
you're talking to Veronica right now.
Boop, boop.
- Mindy's not in there?
- No 'fraid notsie's, 'fraid notsie's.
Notsie, notsie.
- Okay, cause I would love,
I would, Bizzy too, we'd
love to have Mindy here.
- Well Mindy's not here.
But you know who is here?
- Who's that?
- Danielle, I'm Danielle, have we met?
Oh my God, is this your Jacuzzi?
Because it's like, super awesome.
But it's like, kind of too hot.
Well, when I get off this ranch,
I'm probably gonna have a barbecue.
Sylvia, she lives in Florida.
I live in Florida.
I'm just not gonna be able
to stay in this Jacuzzi
with you right now.
- You have to stop.
- Girl, please.
Nigga, what?
- I seriously, I'll hit you in the face.
- I like to sit in my porch
and I like to look at my lawn.
Look at my lawn, look at
those people goin' by my lawn.
- Look at that, another,
do you have an improv background?
- What?
Who's that Bizzy character?
Does Bizzy paw cawcaw
in the harbored yard?
- Seriously, I will put you in my car
and drive you somewhere
and just leave you in
the middle of nowhere.
(speaks in Spanish)
(sings in Spanish)
- I'm gonna go.
- I'll see you inside, okay?
(sings loudly in Spanish)
(laughs)